[Music]
welcome
everybody we're gonna let folks uh have
a minute or two to enter
there's our zoom room thank you so much
for joining us
i'm will torres we'll do some more
introductions later on
but as you settle into our space welcome
even though it might sound strange like
you're here to
hear about the gsb we're really going to
be talking
about you you are the center of all of
this
and i know it might sound a little
strange and it might feel a little
unnatural
um for a lot of folks out there whether
it is your personality maybe it's the
way that you were raised
maybe the community or cultures that you
come from
being in the center of attention feels a
little uncomfortable
i see you i recognize that and i feel
you
i also invite you to take this time to
step back
check in with yourself and think of this
as
as emily said an investment an
investment in the ability
of yourself over the next few years to
be able
to provide for you as well as those
around you
here at stanford we really believe it
all begins with you
when you come to this when you come to
stanford you're going to be joining a
community where change
happens right so maybe it's an idea you
have in one of your classes
that goes on and changes the way that we
interact with each other
that's happened with doordash or embrace
embrace is a low-cost low-tech incubator
for premature babies that has been
shaping the lives of people worldwide
maybe
it's something bigger and you want to
tackle the way that we
engage with poverty or education
social justice we have alumni doing that
work with
african leadership academy or even
impacting everyday lives through michael
loans with kiva
change lives change organizations change
the world
that's our motto and even though
changing the world might seem like a big
ask
never underestimate the power of that
ripple effect
when you see the world from new
perspectives or
have the creative confidence to try
something new
maybe try something different and see it
out till the end
and never underestimate the simple power
of engaging with people
with a new appreciation for who they are
and where they came from
big changes stem from small actions and
that's what we're here to help you with
now let's bring this back to today
um hopefully on this journey you're
asking yourself
three questions so what is it that you
really want to do
so if there's no preconceived notions no
fear of failure
know what should you do what is it that
you want to do
next given that now that you have that
vision
will a management degree from stanford
help you get there
and this is that question that i get all
the time hey will
why should i go to stanford my response
is it's always kind of tough because
for everybody out there the answers are
going to be a little bit different
but it's also an easy response because
i'll ask you these two questions
what do you want to do and from there we
can work together to figure out
what it is that we can provide to help
you get there
and then third question can i get in
sneak preview the answer is yes and
we'll definitely talk about that a
little bit later on
but let's come back to that journey
whether you are thinking about something
near-term long-term
um there's no right or wrong way to get
there
on a map it's easy to draw a straight
line from point a
to point b but in real life there are
going to be pivots
there are going to be inflection points
there might be a u-turn
a second u-turn maybe there's more than
a few u-turns in there
and that's okay this is about creating
the tools so that you can thrive
regardless of what setting you're in
anywhere in the world that you find
yourself this is what we're here to do
we're here to help support you in that
process
so how do we do that we see that
happening across
five different realms so expanding the
way that you think about possibility and
opportunity
thinking along those new frontiers and
also developing that creative confidence
to go
do something with it those ideas have
power
from there think about your community in
different ways
and that's what a lot of this week is
going to be about check out our
community
we're here to share we're here to engage
and create a space where hopefully
you'll see the way that we'll be able to
work towards the future together
as we're working towards that future
thinking about your own leadership
skills
what are your strengths where are areas
for you to improve
and what does that mean for the career
ahead of you
and as you embark on that career
defining your future
the path that you take regardless of
where that takes you
and so knowing us we're going to go into
things in a little bit more detail
and first let's talk about that mindset
so at the gsb you're going to be
engaging
with one of the most amazing groups of
people that you can think about
so you saw with emily and carrie and
dean levin just the way that they were
interacting with each other
you're gonna be joining a class of
people who are inspired and want to
learn
and share and grow with each other this
discovery
of new ideas and perspectives happens
definitely on
our gsb home campus but all across
stanford university
i definitely encourage you to go out
check out classes from across campus
about 80 percent of our students will
take at least one class somewhere else
and as you explore some of these new
paths you might even be able to pick up
a dual or joint degree program along the
way
as you're exploring these paths
definitely maybe
check out that class you've always been
thinking about whether you've had a stem
background
there are going to be speaker series on
policy at the hoover institute
this is a way for you to really explore
some of the new dimensions that are
going to expand the way that you think
about
the world around you and that's what
stanford's about
let's go beyond the traditional
boundaries of academics or
industry or department and bring these
minds together
so you can pick apart the issues and
problems and needs
for today and figure out how to address
them
as you have those ideas again i talk a
lot about creative confidence
let's have the confidence to think about
something new try it and whether
it succeeds or not there's always
something to learn along the way
i know there's a lot of pressure to have
already that it
idea that i'm gonna do x y or z
but on the cornerstone of campus is
inscribed this
dedicated to the things that haven't
happened yet and the people who are
about to dream them up
this is about creating ideas and
creating knowledge
and motivation and inspiration so
in the classroom you're going to be
unpacking over 300 cases by the time you
graduate
you can learn from the experiences of
others but
for different lessons there's also going
to be different teaching methodologies
and that's kind of what makes this such
a dynamic place
you can have experiential moments where
you're going to be taking the lead
maybe it's scenarios or role plays
trying to figure out
maybe it's in the class of managing
growing enterprises
how do you fire or hire or talk to your
board about different directions that
you want to take the company
all of these are real experiences that
you're likely going to have
so let's figure out the pathways that
might feel the most natural
and powerful for you maybe you're taking
one of our action learning courses and
you know do working on real world
problems with some of our partners in
the bay area
all of these innovative methods are to
get you to yes
learn from the experience of those
before you but also
how do you think and lead in real time
it's not just learning about
protagonists but it's about
how can you be the next protagonist
guiding you along this learning and
experiential journey
are going to be some of our
world-renowned faculty members special
shout outs to the two
of our faculty members who just won
nobel prizes economics
this is an environment where we want to
challenge the way that we see and
understand the world around us
a second special shout out to all of our
faculty members
who have been working diligently to
advance issues of diversity equity and
inclusion on campus
you're going to have the opportunity to
meet some of them this week through our
faculty insight series
or maybe you've already gotten to know
some of them maybe it's brian lowry with
um society and power classes race in
america
um that's this evening and that's been
every monday
and that's also accessible as a podcast
so definitely check that out
one of those other questions that i get
pretty frequently is a hesitation
of why should i go to business school i
feel like i'm stepping away from
industry
i don't want to get left behind but i
actually think about it the other way
so you're going to be in this
unprecedented space where you're
actually going to be able to get to the
heart
and future of industry in a whole new
way especially when you get to your
electives
many of them are co-taught by one of our
faculty members
as well as an expert practitioner and so
these are the folks
who are often creating the spaces like
impact investing
um that really define the world as we
see it one of my favorite examples and
i'm a little biased here
is taking a class on strategic pivots
from
a-rod alex rodriguez professional
baseball player turned businessman
turned philanthropist thinking about the
different ways that his career has moved
and what could that mean for you and
your own journey
and it was also a kind of extra special
the jlo sightings on campus but
that's a story for another day stanford
really
is a special place in the way it brings
people together
we're in the heart of the silicon valley
that spirit of innovation
really runs through our veins so whether
it's on campus
across campus the access to things like
maybe you're interested in biotech this
is a research hub of the world
maybe you're interested in vc and
venture like world of venture capital
sandhill road borders campus this is a
gateway to all of the different things
that you might want to engage in
both here and as you go on into the
world um
kind of writ large and then community
stanford is special i've been in a lot
of spaces and stanford is special in the
way it brings together from so many
different backgrounds
around this idea of positive change
and so as we dig into that part of it
comes from
being you when you come to stanford we
want you to feel comfortable
exploring the different things that
create your perspective
as a leader you know tapping into those
experiences of who
and where you come from often create
some of the values
that are going to be the most powerful
things that lead your organization
so whether it is through a program like
talk where one of your classmates
shares their background their hopes and
aspirations
i was invited to one of these standing
room only this was after
classes were over and people turned out
this is about showing up for your
classmates your friends and the people
of your everyday
um and whether it is in person or a
virtual one
i've been into a couple of those as well
that energy is the same
how do we learn and grow and share kind
of
using that strength and power of
vulnerability
collaboration is often like kind of a
buzzword
but for us it comes to life in that
spirit of support
how do you help each other through
classes
whether it is in your finance class or
personal branding
when one vote rises all both arise and
it's in everybody's best interest for
that
equal and open sharing of information
knowledge
and as we like to say feedback is a gift
open honest and candid feedback is one
of the best ways that we can encourage
each other to grow
we have a policy of grade non-disclosure
so it's not that you don't have grades
but we're not posting class ranks or gpa
lists
so we really want you to be able to help
each other be the best use possible
and as you think about the community
we're a class of about an incoming class
of about 420 students
so you're going to get to know each
other at this whole new depth
but that also means something special
for the way you're going to be able to
interact with your alumni
faculty members and the industry experts
that come to campus
every day whether it's in person or on
zoom
so as those folks are helping guide you
through this process
teaching you in classes having
one-on-one coffee chats
maybe it's a little bit of zoo mentoring
going on
this is a way for you to really unpack
that question that kerry mentioned
earlier
why should someone follow you
we already start engaging in some of
this programming your very first term on
campus with leadership labs
where you're going to be working on a
number of different role plays scenarios
with your stanford squad
and this culminates in the executive
challenge where about 150 or so of our
senior level alumni come back to campus
and they're going to be your board and
you'll go through a number of different
simulations throughout the day
to really flex those managerial muscles
that you've been exercising that whole
term
interpersonal dynamics is one of our
most talked about electives
and this is really about how do you show
up in a space
what does that mean for your influence
do things like the words you use
your body language does that have an
unintended
impact on the people around you what
does that mean when you're trying to
communicate with someone very different
from yourself or when you're trying to
motivate a team to some greater purpose
or goal
these are all skills and things that you
want to be able to develop
so that you can have that internal
dialogue so that wherever you are
whatever circumstance you're going to be
in you can adapt
to be the most effective leader that you
can be
we are also committed to principled
leadership um we have this
obligation for to lead ethically and
this is an obligation not just to
ourselves and our values
but to society as a whole
on this journey and again we use this
word journey a lot
but as you go and grow and learn and
meet new folks along the way
you also have the opportunity to define
the road that you're going to be taking
and so it's about creating a career of
impact and a life of meaning
being able to enfold the things that you
love
into the things that you do in your
everyday and
in these small actions as they build up
and create and manifest into great
changes
what does that mean for the
organizations that you belong to
and as society interacts and moves and
evolves
what is the role that you are going to
play in defining what the communities of
tomorrow look like
so what does your future hold
so whether you're thinking about
starting a company maybe you want to
start a movement
maybe you just want to change the
different ways that you approach
problems
tackle questions or talk to the people
around you
there are some amazing things that you
have ahead of you
this is not a placement program and so
while our alumni
definitely enjoy great career outcomes
once they graduate um this is about a
time for you
these two years to define the road that
you want to take the roles and things
that you care about
so that you can pursue those for the
rest of your life
maybe you're using on-campus recruiting
and you go
that route maybe you're working on a
self-directed program with in
partnership with our career management
center
maybe it's evolving organically through
the interactions you're having with our
alumni
these are all pathways to the future all
pathways that can lead you to success
so where is this going to take you where
are you going to end up
hopefully you're going to end up
wherever is going to make you happy
and the tools that you develop at
stanford is going to make it so that you
are going to thrive
regardless of where that might be so
just to recap
five ways that we want to center back on
you
so that you can start this journey of
change expand your mindset
think boldly build your community lead
from the heart
and in doing so have the power to be
that change maker
both for yourself and the people around
you that you love
okay so talk about these steps and um
this might this image might not
necessarily be what you think it is
it's not a tombstone um to my knowledge
phil knight is alive he's doing well so
rest assured we're all good there
um but all over campus are multiple
places of art
and this is actually inscribed on the
ground so that as you're walking onto
campus you're reminded
um this is a quote phil knight founder
of nike
there comes a time in every life when
the past recedes and the future opens
it's that moment when you turn to face
the unknown
some will turn back to what they already
know some will walk straight ahead it's
uncertainty
i can't tell you which one is right but
i can tell you which one is more fun
let's find out where those next steps
are going to take you let's enjoy this
process
and hopefully those next steps will take
you to stanford and we can
be on this journey together but if not i
know you're going to have some amazing
outcomes and a beautiful future
ahead so let's let these words sit in
for a moment
we're gonna switch gears we're gonna
talk a little bit
about admissions so
definitely a little bit of a shift in
mindset here but this next section we're
going to talk about what we look for
where we find it and then some of the
support systems to help you get here
more specifically financial aid so
we practice a holistic review process
that means we are going to take a look
at everything that you submit to get a
sense of who you are
who are you going to show up as in the
classroom and in our community
we're looking at things across three
broad buckets
if you haven't done so already i'd
highly recommend you check out our mba
admissions website
under admissions criteria there's
language about each one of these
sections
there's some rhetorical questions to
help you understand how intellectual
vitality
might come to life for you and in the
case of demonstrative leadership
potential
we actually outlined some of the many
many many leadership competencies
that you might be expressing in your
everyday life
but while we're here together let's talk
about each one of these
just briefly so intellectual vitality
i think about this it's definitely much
more than gpa
or test scores notice those are not the
words here it's intellectual vitality
i think about this as in your life there
are a lot of different people
and you have a lot of different
relationships out there and that's great
what's your relationship with knowledge
what are the things that you get excited
to learn about how do you learn about it
and because of the type of place the gsb
is how do you share that knowledge with
others
for demonstrated leadership potential
you can already break this up into two
chunks
demonstrated leadership and leadership
potential
you don't have to have had a leadership
role to have demonstrated leadership
qualities
and leadership qualities can emerge in
so many different places
maybe it's in the classroom maybe it's
in the community
for sure it might be the workplace but
it could also be at home
stepping up to lead or take over in a
time of crisis with your family
regardless of where these things show up
we honor
recognize and empower you to do so
and then personal qualities and
contributions
so i like to ask the question who
are you maybe there's elements of your
background your upbringing
the cultures and environments that
you've moved through your lived
experience and the decisions that you've
had to make that brought you to the here
and now
how do those things shape your
perspective how do you share that
perspective and how that
how does that motivate the things that
you want to do next
we learn as much from each other as we
do from
the textbooks and cases that we study
and this is one of those things where
as you start to learn about yourself it
opens up a new lens for you to be able
to learn
embrace and engage with those around you
so where do we find it so i mentioned
earlier that we're taking a look at all
of the different things that you submit
so here are eight things laid out so
education again
no it does not say gpa specifically
that's part of it
but gpa is a single data point there's
so much more to your education
we're looking at your transcripts what
classes have you taken
however you performed in those different
classes with testing
yes we require either a gmat or the gre
but we don't have a preference for one
or the other there's no minimums no
benchmarks
there's no score cutoff where below that
will toss you out
or above that you're an automatic in it
really is a holistic understanding
of the entire year for activities
and work history you can think about
that as both your resume
and the part of the application we're
asking you to tell us a little bit more
about that
it might feel a little redundant at
first that hey i'm already submitting my
resume why do i still have to fill out
this work history part in the
application
but if you look at the questions and the
type of responses and information you
can provide
those can be two very different and
complementary spaces this is a different
way for us to learn about you
i think about this as the application is
the story of who you are
and every good story is made up of
details
every blank space in our application or
the resume
is an opportunity to tell us a little
bit of something about yourself to get
us
and help us to that place where we can
understand you to the best degree
possible
so letters of recommendation so you
require two
and we recommend that one is from your
direct supervisor but we know that's not
always possible
we never want to preclude you from a
raise or bonus or a promotion
and you know sometimes you don't
necessarily want to tell your manager
that you might be thinking about leaving
because
you know that might be compromised or
maybe you
are part of a family business and you
know there's a little bit of a conflict
of interest if your
mom or your dad is your boss um or maybe
you're
you own a company yourself and you are
the boss
check out our mba admissions website
there is a space there that has much
more information than letters of
recommendation
we asked three general questions of all
of our recommenders so
how is this person performed relative to
equally qualified peers
tell us about a time where there was
feedback and then there's that third
cash all
is there anything else we should know
based on those questions we really do
trust you to choose whoever can write
the the
most robust letter for you as possible
essays and so later on this week this
wednesday we're gonna have uh
two essay workshops a morning and an
encore afternoon
session for those who might not be able
to make that morning session because of
either work or time zones
and we'll definitely unpack a lot more
there but this is an
opportunity for us to learn more about
you from your own words
there's no right or wrong answers but
really digging into
the things that you hoped to achieve who
you are
and what that means um for your journey
there are also optional short questions
and so these are literally optional if
you are already telling us the same
things and the takeaway is the same
don't have to do it but if there's
something new that you want us to know
these can be a great place to let us
know that and then interviews
so most of our interviews are going to
be done by alumni and they're all going
to be done
um they're behavioral based by
invitation
and so the nice thing is you're already
the expert in you
we're going to be asking you questions
about things you've done how you've done
them
and then hopefully over the course of
that time you're also able to interact
and
ask questions of our alumni and really
get to know each other and see the
stanford community
um the way we do
and so walking through that application
process
you're admitted congratulations welcome
it's an investment the same way that
emily mentioned
for more than one reason and so
financial aid is one of those things
that we really care about and is really
important to us
in enabling students of all backgrounds
to be able to attend the gsb
um we are need blind when it comes to
admission so that means we
are not taking a look at how you're
going to fund your time as part of the
admissions process
but we're need based for our financial
aid and so this means after admission
we reach out with instructions for how
to apply
and so our financial aid process is
geared around
three things so access equity and
excellence
again we want folks from all backgrounds
for stanford to be a realistic option
for them
we want to admit the best talent from
wherever in the world
it's coming from and we want people to
know what's going into the financial aid
process
so they can plan appropriately later on
today we are actually having
a financial aid session with some of our
financial aid officers
experts in the process so definitely
tune in if you want to learn more there
but at a high level um there are
multiple ways that we support you
last year the average fellowship was
about forty thousand dollars
folks will bring in external
scholarships for us military veterans
um who are eligible there's a yellow
ribbon program who will cover tuition
and
uh mandatory fees there's also the
knight hennessey scholars program it's a
separate program that you can apply for
that will cover up to three years of
graduate study at stanford
and this year we're really excited to
announce the launch of the bold
fellows fund and so this is funding on
top
of the generous need-based financial aid
knowing that
you know sometimes it's more than just
your own individual me that you must
that you're considering
maybe you are the primary breadwinner
for your family
or you are going to be in the future
this is an opportunity to help make up
some of that difference
so that you can really take in that
holistic view of need
and stanford can be a realistic place
for you to come grow
and thrive
and so with that think about this
process again as a journey
getting ready for it what are the things
that you want to know that's what we're
here for all week long
definitely check in with us we have a
ask an admission officer
session this friday so if you have
questions about the process along the
way
that's going to be amazing place to
check in with us talk to students
ask your questions and really get a
sense for how they've come to terms with
their career paths the things that they
hope to achieve and what they're doing
here on campus
and so it all starts with stanford
it all starts with you and take this
moment
to center your conversation on the
things that you're interested
we're here to help i'm going to stop
share there and we
are going to transition over to the
question and answers
so i'm going to open the q a box and i'm
going to be taking questions live
our crew is gonna continue answering
questions
in that box as well so definitely um go
ahead
and pop those questions there so we have
a question here
from andre and so this might be a
question on a lot of folks
mine minds when can we expect to have
classroom classes again
um will anything change in the way
classes used to be so very much on the
classroom experience
um and so we are in this lucky position
so right now a lot of your classes are
going to be zoom
but for some of your smaller sessions so
think lead labs with your squad of six
we're actually um having small groups
meet
outdoors so you're able to interact and
have some of those like personal
connections and opportunities to learn
together
and so stanford university is keeping an
eye on both the local as well as
university health best practices because
ultimately our priority is your health
and safety
so we really hope that the situation
will be that everybody can be back
in class in person very soon but until
then we're working together to make sure
that we can find the best of both worlds
so they didn't mention this earlier but
emily and carrie were part of
a autumn quarter task force that
comprised of
students faculty and administration to
really make sure
that the experience for our students
really maximizes those two things
health and safety as well as the
experience
all right here's a question from adana
um financial times indicates profile
information
for business schools including how many
students are offered internships
at places where they in are offered
internships
stanford's ranking seemed a little lower
than one might have expected compared to
other schools in the top ten
i read through the financial times
methodology would you be so kind as to
shed some light from stanford's
perspective
on the reason why this might be and so
this is a question that might actually
be in a lot of people's minds i know
that the rankings
out there from different organizations
can be a way for you to
triangulate um some of the different
opportunities that you're thinking about
um and what i would say is i'm going to
come back to something that happened
this year
and so it might not be speaking
specifically to the methodologies
being used by the different ranking
systems but this is about the experience
and opportunities that are going to be
here for you
and so career management center will
often work with folks to figure out what
potential internships might be if you're
thinking about social entrepreneurship
or kind of the social impact space uh
the
center for social innovation will often
work with students as well to help
think about opportunities there who are
alumni that we might be able to connect
with
um and then never underestimate the
power of both our alumni network
and your classmate network there have
been
so many instances where internships have
arisen from like
chance encounters and intentional like i
know someone who
and connections based on interest this
year
um as kovid kind of took the world by
storm and we were adapting to that new
normal
and many companies were really thinking
about the resources that they were
investing
into internships and so knowing how
important this is for our students
dean levin actually put a call out to
our alumni
for any opportunities both internships
and full-time positions that
would be available for our students uh
the return was kind of amazing in that
there were more
opportunities than our students could
fill
and i think independent of any kind of
ranking system or methodology
it's this network that really cares and
is trying to
find ways to make sure you're able to
maximize your time at the gsp
i think that's where that value comes
into play so i kind of took a little bit
of a u-turn and side
side track there but hopefully that um
that helps you get a sense for the
community itself
so here we go um
question here about interviews and so
for those who
might not be um in the u.s
so for our interviews when they were in
person they would be
with one of our alumni who was in your
area
uh so dugbo i think you mentioned here
uh not in america so it would be someone
in your location
this year they are being done virtually
which actually opens up a whole new
world of potential alumni interviewers
and community members for you to connect
with so no worries on that front at all
all right ah here's a great question
from eleanor about deferral
so the question is does the admission
process look any different
for deferred enrollment and when is a
good round to submit the application for
that
so we offer limited deferrals at the gsb
typically for folks who are still in
either their final year of college or
maybe they've
just gone through college and then
straight into a grad program and then
are applying to the gsp
the deferral program is so that you have
some time to go
into the workforce and then bring back
that experience to campus
for everybody else we definitely
recommend for you to apply for the year
you want to start
before our deferrals um we it's actually
the exact same application and the exact
same process
we are still looking for that same sense
of intellectual vitality
demonstrated leadership potential and
personal qualities and contributions
that we look for in all of our students
for our college students so we do not
have a work experience requirement
and so part of the holistic review
process is taking a moment to understand
your context
so the opportunities that you have
available to you might
look very different from someone who's
been in the workforce for two to three
years and that's going to look very
different than the opportunities than
that someone might have had if they've
been working 5
6 7 or 12 years so really thinking about
how have you maximized the opportunities
available to you
in terms of rounds so round for direct
enrollment no real difference between
round one and round two
round three can often seem a little bit
more challenging because we have filled
most of our seats in our class by then
but we always do admit folks in round
three
for our deferral students since you are
going to be in a class later in the
future
that's not necessarily part of the same
consideration process
um so for many of you round three might
actually be a good idea
for college seniors that gives you more
time your senior year to do things
oftentimes this is a year when you might
have some leadership potential
or leadership roles or are doing some
internships
so this gives you more time to kind of
build up your experience set
and maybe have experiences you want to
talk about in that application
all right here's a question from rashmi
how has the global experiences program
been adapted in light of the pandemic
so great question here i think this has
been one of those spaces that we
continue to evolve
as we take best practices and as we
monitor the travel policies not just
of the university but also of the
different countries
that our folks might be going to so last
year
um we there's a program called the gmix
the graduate management immersion
experience
you can think about that almost as an
internship somewhere in the world
during the summer between your mba 1 and
mba 2 year
so last year many of them shifted to
virtual
and hopefully we're going to be able to
offer those again virtually this summer
not knowing what the exact travel
possibilities are going to look like
i know our global studies department is
working really really hard to
figure out different ways to incorporate
those global perspectives
into your education and so actually one
of those new programs this year is
global dialogues
which brings together students from all
different backgrounds speakers from all
over the world
to talk about what does it mean to both
create community
and engage with others regardless of
what cultural or geographic
setting you're in how do you step back
have some of the internal dialogue that
allows you to unpack
both you know the individual group and
environment factors
that might influence the way that you
need to carry yourself
to be effective so multiple ways there
more space for evolution and it's
definitely something that the school is
keeping an eye on because
that global experience and global
perspective
is a really important part of kind of
your development journey
all right um question here
um from puja earlier we heard so i
talked about different teaching methods
this year a lot of classes are online
where simulation and action leadership
classes affected
so yes and no so there has been an
evolution in some of the course
offerings some of them have been shifted
more online
as i mentioned earlier some of them are
meeting in small group sessions
outdoors we're lucky enough to be in
california where
the environment allows for us to have
outdoor classes all the way into the
fall and
into the winter really so some of those
courses are still being held
in very much the same format or very
similar formats to what they used to be
and actually very interesting silver
lining to
some of the classes being online because
of this
newfound like um fluency with zoom
it opens up a whole new world of who is
visiting as case protagonist who's
engaging with students
whether it is globally this is a whole
new range of diversity and perspectives
that has opened up to us so there have
also been some really interesting silver
linings to the experience along the way
all right so we're getting close to the
top of the hour
um right now i really want to encourage
you so we might not have gone to all the
questions in the q
a box but we have a whole week of
exploration
with diversity and leadership many more
sessions featuring
admissions staff so bring those
questions there if they're not already
answered
or if you don't find the answer by
exploring our website
you know this is another time to to come
talk to us and be
a part of um the experience
again registration for events is open
all week long so
maybe you're curious to hear a little
bit more about the experience for
active duty or military veterans or
you're thinking about
hey i'm curious about working in latin
america
check out the session featuring our
global some of our global interest clubs
including the latin american student
association texas club and the midwest
club
really thinking about that vertical time
zone slice some of the different
aspects that can really complement your
experience here at the gsb
so with that thank you so much for
joining us for the kickoff
i hope to see you throughout this week
and
regardless if you're starting the day or
ending your day
thank you again for joining us stay safe
stay hydrated find moments of support
solidarity and gratitude you too can go
out there
change lives change organizations and
change the world we'll see you soon